what happened with George yeah this is
what I want to get to the bottom line so
I want to say something number one he
hasn't reached out to me told him two I
told him too he didn't number two he
said he sees you you're fans
online has said I can't be a fan of
yours me until you make it right with
George that's number two I got a lot of
flack from it all right and number three
I want to tell you something right I
found it to be number one I don't even
know what the [ __ ] I did and number two
why did he leave it was my fault why
because I
played into not played into I pointed
out that he was no longer paying
attention because we shut down some of
his vulnerable vulnerable moments in the
podcast
Bobby Bobby it was his fault
[Music]
Bobby you were right you were right and
don't let my audience get to you bro
they can be they can be I understand
specific sometimes and they love their
Georgie but you can't you can't get you
don't give a [ __ ] bro I do no you don't
it's like the softy of the show yes but
that's why he's on the show that's why
he's on the show you don't know that you
don't know that that's why he's there
Mike Mike is that Alpha that I hate I
hate Mike right but I need someone on
the podcast because everyone likes but
he's ugly Mike's so ugly he's ugly
compared to you he's ugly no I just
think he's Baseline ugly oh he has like
I'm just kidding I'm just kidding like a
circus seat like the the pinheads back
in the 50s
no no no no no no I asked Mike actually
yesterday what he would rate himself on
a scale of one to ten yeah he said seven
there's no way well because he's tall
he's six three that helps and you know
what yeah he's hilarious he's very funny
he's funnier also off camera yeah so
like man like great personality dude he
loves hamburgers loves hamburgers we
love that you loved him I love
hamburgers I've been to but he still has
a beautiful beard yeah yeah yeah no no
look here's what happened George got
vulnerable Bobby said his monologue was
too long it was too long it was too long
I I thought it was funny he was in Jess
and you're with the comedian you got to
be willing to go from A to B to C oh
whoa whoa whoa look at there he is right
there yeah the guy with the eyebrows so
so someone bought this picture all of
our noses look just massive like I don't
know what about this picture that we
could all use a rhinoplasty yeah those
noses are [ __ ] unusual songs wait but
big big noses are all the rage with
women right now I think really there's
like just a whole movement of women like
just specifically wanting big noses in
men is that was that the follow-up to
the dad bod oh I think so which Mike
also has by the way he's got a dad but
he has a big nose I'm telling you he's
he's desirable dude wow why he's he's
just a [ __ ] man and why why because he's
got so much confidence and he doesn't
give a [ __ ] about anything right he
doesn't give a [ __ ]
but he kind of does but not really he's
just he's great he's a great co-host
it's so is George and again like he he
is the sensitive one and and you and we
we've upset him but Bobby he apologizes
no [ __ ] you man let me say something
okay I love you sorry for attacking you
can always attack I'm going to
I'm not gonna stop I'm not afraid I'm
not afraid right what's that put that
down nerd
what do you have [ __ ] what is that
it's a Rubik's Cube I know I know what
it is but like oh yeah like OCD or
something like that or yeah yeah yeah
okay good that's your thing
I I learned it two days ago oh really
okay very good you matched it so my
point is this that was intentional
okay but can I get to my point my point
is what he did was unprofessional yeah I
was a guest he walked out on a guest if
this guy right here walked out on a
guest he would be reprimanded hell
two-month suspension oh whoa walking out
I guess I would feel so much shame yeah
yeah what's this just showing for the
audience oh yeah just yeah yeah just see
it you want to skip to the end he is oh
you did yeah yeah I know George has been
under a tremendous
don't stop George I want you over here
with me George I want you over here and
chase him down
you find him George no go get him go get
him he I try I said
wait can we keep playing it just for one
second yeah yeah we're gonna have to
deal with the Fallout of this episode
I swear to God Bobby Lee you [ __ ]
pissed off my co-host he's probably
crying in the driveway oh Mike was yeah
you know the Beatles could have lost
Ringo
[Laughter]
that's good that's good oh
that's a funny joke it was hilarious it
was so [ __ ] funny yeah you're so
funny if you walked out if you had
walked out right it would have been like
oh it's over
right if you had walked out right but
him walking out was just kind of like
let's keep going
[Music]
we didn't stop did we did another 20
minutes right we actually went home that
was that was the the thing that was kind
of actually a big deal I thought it was
a bit no it wasn't a bit ubered out we
chased him after that like seconds later
we left he never came back never let me
tell you something yeah he apologized on
the episode of impulsor that's coming
out tomorrow he was he was he was
because I told him to reach out I said
you should reach out to Bobby can you
give me his number can we FaceTime I can
give you I can can you give me anything
you want to settle this right now yeah
I'm going to call him right now
no I'll FaceTime him okay
are you expecting apology no we'll
figure it out how about it's just like a
like a double knockout just like both
apologize at the same time I didn't do
anything wrong I didn't do anything
wrong I'm not positing for something
yeah yeah
but I'll make it right there we go okay
I'll make it right I like that yeah yeah
this show is sponsored by Ridge wallet
Ridge wallet oh my God I felt like for
years
doing this podcast I I in my head I'm
like where is ridgewallet we've been
we've been